Let us solve some of the issues of the foundations
Which require a division
If I ask you what is the result of 5 ^ 6
5 5 ^ 2?
Well, we can go for the basic definition
For the foundations we say that 5 ^ 6
Means 5 × 5 × 5 × 5 × 5
X 5
5 multiplied by itself six times
And 5 ^ 2, is 5 multiplied by itself twice, ie
Is equal to 5 × 5
Well, we know how we can simplify a fraction or relative phrase
Like this
We can divide the numerator and set it to 5
Then we delete, then divide on
5 Others, delete these 5 and those
What will we have left?
5 × 5 × 5 × 5/1, or can say that
5 ^ 4
Now, notice what will happen
We started with 6 in rugs, 5
Multiplied by itself six times in rugs, then
We put up
We could have put the 2 in the place
So we have 5 ^ 6-2
That is, we could have put the Ace in
The place with the bass in the rugs
Let us remember how this can be attributed to beatings
If I had 5 ^ - let me use a different color
5 ^ 6 × 5 ^ 2, as seen in
Another offer that this equals 5 ^ 6 + -
I try to make the colors distinctive here - 6 + 2
Now, we have a new property
In the next show, we will see that these two are not
Are different
They are really two sides of one coin, when we learn
More on negative grounds
But in this video, we saw that 5 ^ 6
Divide on 5 ^ 2 - Let me type it
In a different color - and the output is
5 ^ 6-2
Ie 5 ^ 4
Here is equal to 5 ^ 8
When we hit two numbers with the same foundation, we collect
The foundations
When we divide and have the same foundation, we ask
Assam is the first of its kind
Let's solve a bunch of additional examples of this
What is the result of 6 ^ 7.
6 ^ 3?
Well, again, the same property can be followed
This equals 6 ^ 7 - 3, which is equal to
6 ^ 4
We can beat it this way as we did in
The first issue we realized is that it is equal
6 ^ 4
Let's try something interesting now
It will be completed in the next video
Suppose we have 3 ^ 4.
3 ^ 10
Well, if we follow the basic rules, this will be equal
3 × 3 × 3 × 3, all this divided by 3 × 3
3 × 3 × 3 × 3
× 3 × 3 We must have 10 of the number 3
how much?
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten
Well, if we do the same as what we did in the last video, this will delete the 3
With those 3
Delete these 3
And we have 1 / - one, two, three
Four, five, six
If 1/3 ^ 6, right?
We have 1/3 ^ 6
But the content of this property I talked about
This equals 3 ^ 4 - 10
Okay
How much is the product of 4 - 10?
We will get a negative number
Which is 3 ^ -6
If we use this property, we will get the output
3 ^ 6
And when we hit them we will get
1/3 ^ 6
The fun part of all this is that for those
Same amount
If you think you now realize what it means
We have a number raised for negative
3 ^ -6 = 1 /
3 ^ 6
I will solve many examples in
Next video
But if you raise any number for a negative force, for example
a ^ -b, this is equivalent to 1 / a ^ b
These two images are two sides of a single coin
At the beginning of this video, we saw that if we had a ^ b
/ a ^ c, this equals a ^ b-c
This is another property that we have used
Now, to use what we have learned now and what we have learned in
The latter offer, in solving more complex problems
Let's say I have a ^ 3 b ^ 4)
/ a ^ 2 b) ^ 3
Well, we can use the property we learned to simplify
The amount inside
This is equal to - a ^ 3
/ a ^ 2
Is a ^ 3 - 2 equal?
Its final simplification would be a
You can imagine, this is a × a × a
/ a × a
We have a left in the rugs
We now come to our b words b ^ 4 b b
This is equal to b ^ 3 true?
Ie b ^ 1
Because 4 - 1 = 3, and then all this amount within the parentheses is raised
Force 3
And we do not want to forget the 3 power here
Power 3 These are the same ones
Let me do it
Force 3, then this a
Written in orange is the same as a here
I think we understand the relationship between each value
Now the property can be used when we multiply
Number and raise it to force 3, this is equal
a ^ 3 × b ^ 3
All raised to power 3
This equals a ^ 3
a ^ 3 I will write it here
X b ^ 3 × 3 × b ^ 9
We want to simplify this
As much as possible
Let us solve another example
I think it's a good and valuable training
You will gain experience later
Suppose we have 25xy ^ 6 /
20y ^ 5 x ^ 2
If again, we can rearrange the numerator and
Maqamat
We can write as follows: 25/20 x
x / x ^ 2, right?
We created the denominator 20x ^ 2 y ^ 5
It does not matter which order we follow - x y ^ 6
/ y ^ 5
Let's use the property we've just learned
To simplify the fractions
25/20, if we divide each of the numerals and denominator on 5
We'll get 5/4
x x x ^ 2 - Well, there are two methods
To think about these
We can consider it x ^ -1
We have 1 power here
1 - 2 = -1
If this equals x ^ -1
Or equal to 1 / x
Both are equal
Let's take this picture
1 / x so
It will be x / x x x
One of the x deletions
Our remaining 1 / x
Finally, y ^ 6 / y ^ 5
Equals y ^ 6 - 5 which equals
y ^ 1 or y if y
If we want to write all this in a way
One relative term, as follows, is 5 × 1 × y
Which is equal to 5y and all this divided by 4 x x
These y / 1 if 4 x x x 1 each this amount divided by 4x
We have simplified it